thank you Paul for calling this
important press conference uh I am sure
in fairness the President Bush that
there are some people were really
enthusiastic about his tax relief
program I happen not to know any of
those people are and most of those
people I suspect are people who make
millions if not billions of dollars a
year and I suppose from their point of
view they think it's a great idea that
the richest 1% of the population should
receive forty percent of the tax breaks
of what I can honestly tell you is
someone who goes around the state of
Vermont a whole lot knocks on a lot of
doors holds a lot of town meetings I
have not heard one Vermont to ever tell
me that Bernie the highest priority of
the United States Congress should be to
give huge tax breaks to millionaires and
billionaires people tell me a lot of
things nobody has ever told me that now
it seems to me that when you look at the
crisis of education and when you hear
politician after politician talking
about the needs of education then that
tax proposal that mr. bush is proposing
is an absolute disgrace let's look at
just some of the realities of what's
going on in education today the average
graduate of a four-year college in this
country ends up twenty thousand dollars
in debt not including the debt incurred
by his or her parents that means that
there are kids not going to the
college's they want to go to not going
to college at all having to choose
careers they otherwise would not choose
because of that huge debt meanwhile over
the years Pell grants and other federal
student aid programs have in no way kept
up with a high class of college
inflation the idea of giving tax breaks
to billionaires and not adequately
funding student needs for higher
education is a total disgrace last week
I happen to me with a number of child
care providers in the state of Vermont
and I expect that the story they told me
is not different than any other state in
this country what we are doing for
infant
in this country is abysmal it is a
disgrace it is criminal we have child
care workers all over this country who
are earning six or seven dollars an hour
who do not have benefits who do not have
chaining children at the most vulnerable
age of their lives are not getting the
proper nutrition are not getting the cup
of proper nurturing that they need and
these are the kids who are now becoming
more violent who will do worse in school
who will end up in jail so instead of
investing in tax breaks for billionaires
it seems to me a lot more sensible that
we provide significant increases in
child care funding years ago the United
States Congress made a pledge to school
systems all over this country and it
said that if you mainstream children
with disabilities we will provide forty
percent of the funding meanwhile in
Vermont and in school districts all over
America school systems are struggling
because they have in fact mainstream
their kids which is an expensive
proposition but the federal government
has in no way kept its commitment in
terms of that forty percent of funding
to we ignore those realities of higher
education of child care of special
education of a dozen other areas in
education and saying we think a more
important priority as tax breaks for
billionaires is absolutely immoral and
absurd and I can tell you that the
Progressive Caucus is going to fight
this tooth nail we're going to go to the
American people and we're going to stop
these outrageous tax breaks for people
who don't need them